deswegen würde ich sagen ist das quasi
meine letzte folge von minecraft galaxy
die gründe habe ich euch jetzt genannt
und ich muss allerdings sagen freunde
euch erwartet bald einen mega geil es
neues projekt hallo ich meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
diesem wundervollen sonntagmorgen
sonntagmorgen hieß es freitag ist es
freitag
oh mein gott jedenfalls habe ich mir
gedacht ihr einige kennen was ist testen
denn einfach sondern komischen kopf aus
und mut einige kennen eventuell noch
diese welt da oben ist stieß schiff da
unten ist es von msi experte ich geh mal
wieder kurz zurück im fledermaus hier
damit ihr das ganze also ein bisschen
damit wir somit in rom schauen kann da
hinten ist das baumhaus von unserem team
foxtrott hier ist mein haus da ist meine
wundervolle statue und hier haben
beispielsweise sonnig und kran crafter
gewohnt hier unten war glaube ich mci
experten schnee stege weiter oben
dahinten wer da ist weiß ich gar nicht
mehr echter bismarck war da oder
demnächst weiter hinten irgendwo da ist
auch noch eine kleine bude
da ist der spalt wo max eine fledermaus
bekommen hat erhält es auch so etwas
also
ihr wie ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon im
titel gelesen es ist minecraft galaxy
und viele denken jetzt wahrscheinlich
obwohl es steht ja im titel
viele haben wahrscheinlich gedacht so jo
es geht weiter mit minecraft galaxy
nachdem ich hier so motiviert angefangen
habe mit technik und alle möglichen
schwarze was habe ich denn die
eigentlich magnetic dynamo das habe ich
mit max gemacht er war noch voller
erstaunen dass ich das so schnell
hinbekommen habe ich habe diese ganze
farben gemacht und halt so ein paar
sachen make nice uns ein paar sachen
halt immer mich darum gekümmert die ich
mir alle die umsätze wollte hat ist ein
paar pläne die ich machen wollte und
letztendlich ist es halt so gekommen
dass ich quasi nicht wirklich quasi
daran weitergearbeitet haben in der
letzten zeit als es kam gar keinen
galaxy das sag ich jetzt mal einfach so
es war halt so ist kann ja kein galaxy
und der grund darin und ich einfach dass
mir das ganze keinen spaß mehr gemacht
habe ich möchte ehrlich mit euch sein
ich fahre auch im letzten video wo ich
gesagt habe dass es nur noch hält gibt
habe ich gesagt ich mache das was ich
möchte auf youtube das was mir spaß
macht und galaxy war so eine sache
so hatte zum beispiel auch kates gesagt
wer und der auch ein sehr guter freund
von mir ist dass er meinte auch zu mir
am anfang ja kommen ich teste das mal
aus wie das ganze wohl wir top das
irgendwie was habe ich eigentlich alles
für sie
dieser platz ist auch an ich hatte
irgendwie dass wir das ganze erst mal
abwarten und schauen wie sich das ganze
entwickelt
ich glaube dieser reihe kriegt ihr nicht
genügend licht deswegen wechsel nie was
ich bin jetzt einfach ab
dass wir das ganze erst mal abwarten wie
das ganze wird wie es uns gefällt und
mir hat
ehrlich gesagt am anfang richtig gut
gefallen nur dann kam also wieder die
zeit wo sich zu allem it technik
beschäftigt hat und man selber hängt
dann halt immer so ein bisschen
hinterher
und bei mir war es dann halt auch so
dass ja ich weiß nicht so nix gegen euch
aber so ein paar leute mal in den
kommentaren ekd und der hat doch dies um
dies und der untertasse passt das war
meistens nicht mal böse gemeint aber das
machen sagt mir natürlich schon so okay
wenn der schirm hat dann muss ich mich
damit eventuell auch mal beschäftigen
aber das ist einfach das mag ich nicht
so wenn ich mich mit irgendwas so stark
auseinander setzen muss wofür ich mich
nicht wirklich interessiere ich habe
lust an minecraft etwas zu erforschen
deswegen hero war quasi ich glaube
dieses projekt geliebt wie sonstwas hero
war genau das wo obwohl ich da auch
anfangsschwierigkeiten hatte aber nie
war genau das wo man erforschen konnte
wo man überall so dungeons waren die man
machen konnte blabla
hier gibt's natürlich auch solche sachen
aber hebels auch soviel wieder mit
technik sowie megaprojekt ich habe mega
projekt über 100 gebrauchte mich mit
technik auseinanderzusetzen weil ich da
nie so lust hatte ich bin zu dieser
oldschool minecraft der so lust auf
solche ganz normalen sachen hat irgendwo
aufnehmen den wert aufs kommentieren
setzen blabla und dann als auch mal
einen dino gestorben das hat mit den
dinos nicht alles geklappt und es sind
man immer so rückschläge
es hat sich alles so tragisch an
letztendlich ist es halt so ich bin froh
und ich habe auch ich bin froh dass ich
dabei war dass das ganze mal mitspielen
durfte und hier unten habe ich auch
immer noch ein paar pläne gehabt die ich
jetzt doch nicht mehr umsetzen konnte
wie beispielsweise unten war eine
riesige baum fahren und meine ganze
farbe habe ich nach unten verlegen sogar
damit ich oben seinen kompletten
wohnraum habt ihr sieht auch schon
relativ cool aus mit denen mit der sieht
aus wie so ein bisschen unserem sonne
sonnenschein sondern mauer irgendwie in
sonneberg finde ich relativ cool alles
fand ich auch so total cool
allerdings habe ich dann halt mit galaxy
mal hab ich gedacht okay ich habe heute
noch kein galaxy macht ich lass mal
lieber ich mal lieber ein anderes video
vielleicht wollte ich mal was anderes
ihn als galaxy plan gedacht okay das
andere video kann jetzt viel besser an
als galaxy mach ich doch normal anderes
video macht dies macht an das blabla und
hab galaxy quasi gar nicht vermisst und
jetzt nur als jetzt letztens mal ganz
ganz viele kommentare kam ja wo es
eigentlich lx ihn habe ich mir gedacht
ach ja stimmt das habe ich auch noch und
deswegen hab ich mir gedacht das ist
quasi das letzte video minecraft galaxy
ich würde euch gern den downloadlink von
meinem haus geben und von der
falls der im ausland machen wollte aber
das kann ich halt nicht weil das immer
noch leute spielen ich glaub an guten
spiels noch spark weiß ich auch noch das
nette spielt ich will mir gar nicht mehr
sicher wer überhaupt noch alles dabei
ist weil max zum beispiel nicht mehr
dabei mit dem ich sehr viel hier gemacht
habe den ich auch sehr sehr gern habe
als ich vor schulen aber so als freund
ist ein richtig guter freund von mir und
der macht hat auch nicht mehr in x-men
galaxy und so ich weiß nicht also
irgendwie für mich ist es so aus diese
motivation
deswegen würde ich sagen ist das quasi
meine letzte folge von minecraft galaxy
die gründe habe ich euch jetzt genannt
und ich muss allerdings sagen freunde
euch erwartet bald einen mega geil es
neues projekt also das wird nix großes
mit mit 20 30 youtube oder so sondern
was kleineres ich hab schon bei twitter
gepostet links in der beschreibung dass
bald ein neues projekt mit rewe kommt da
der es mit in dem projekt noch zwei
andere youtuber da könnt ihr aber raten
wer das ist und dann
da haben wir da auch ein paar sachen
rausgesucht und dann richtig cooles
konzept das ist nicht sondern nicht so
ein großes projekt also große projekte
kommen ja noch war o2 etc sondern das
ist wirklich so was was wir zu viert
machen wollten etwas kleineres und ja da
da da kommt so ein neues projekt ich
hoffe auch dass wir durch gefallen es
wird euch auf jeden fall gefallen und
das ist jetzt also mein abschied aus
minecraft galaxy ich weiß nicht sagt mir
einfach so nochmal kurz gesagt hat mir
am ende nicht mehr viel spaß gemacht und
ich möchte nichts auf einem kanal bringt
es mir keinen spaß macht alle leute die
mich jetzt schon lange abonniert haben
wissen wahrscheinlich eine zeit lang
kamen bei mir nur webspace davon dann
kam eine zeitlang mal vielfalt ankam
derzeit nur mit videos und jetzt derzeit
ist es so dass ich bock auf ganz ganz
viele verschiedene sachen habe also
beispielsweise kräftig mit den mod
vorstellungen web reviews pvp-kämpfe
habe ich mich ab ob bosse und sondern
ein paar sachen die halt richtig an
nämlich die bock habt die ich auch gerne
produziere und wo ich sage zu kommen
lass mal lieber noch eine folge
aufnehmen ich hab voll bock das weiter
zu zocken anstatt bei minecraft galaxy
eurosport galaxy für heute
deswegen habe ich gedacht ich beende das
ganze lieber das tut mir relativ leid
für euch die das gefeiert haben und die
alle meinen computer minecraft galaxy
allerdings es ist halt wie ich in dem
video schon gesagt habe youtube
broadcast yourself macht das was macht
das was dir spaß macht hat das hoch was
du willst und das ist quasi meine
entscheidung ich möchte kein minecraft
galaxy mehr hochladen und es wird
allerdings bald was neues kommen dass
plan wenigstens wochenende und ich würde
sagen warum ich hier hängt dann hat
das recht zur uni nach hamburg fahren
und dann wieder irgendwie um die 300
kilometer die ich dann mit meiner eben
zurücklegen muss deswegen lasse das
ganze video jetzt mal unter zehn minuten
hoffentlich ich würde sagen wenn ich
mein kreft galaxy gefallen hat dann
zeigt es mir mit einem daumen hoch und
ich möchte nicht dass jetzt ein daumen
runter geht da irgendwie beleidigt nur
weil es mal als ist halt meine
entscheidung und ich denke das sollte
man respektieren
irgendwann gibt die welt bestimmt zum
download und dann werde ich euch noch
mal ein video machen und die will sollte
an
freut euch auf das neue projekt und dann
will ich sagen ich gehe es letzte mal
von diesem server herunter ich hoffe
trotzdem hat das video einigermaßen
gefallen und ihr könnt mich verstehen
und dann würde ich sagen meine
village.de